[Music]
dead-tired news submitted by I need more
jkn me too
that's so naughty thank you ER doctor
died of exhaustion after treating 40
patients in one shift
wow what a hero that is a lot of
patients he saved 40 point bull karnov
it's a lot I've never worked as a nurse
chin will you give your life to save 40
people because I I want oh that's that
we're not who are the 40 people and what
are their credentials children on their
prize strangers random people hmm what
if it's 40 of your closest family and
friends that's like everybody which
one's the ones that you like your
favorites some people my own wedding on
my own another your I don't think I have
40 of them clothes not even have 40
close friends what about 40 people that
you know somehow you know this in the
future they're gonna do a lot of good
they could give my life for my wife
hundred percent no problem but even then
I'd probably die like a coward like you
don't I mean like I don't think I'd die
in a cool way like I will replace my
life for my wife's life I probably like
[Laughter]
a realistic hero
oh yeah that would suck yeah if you gave
your life for her and also she [ __ ]
marry somebody else to [ __ ] someone else
nah they seem for the mystery of life
right I'd be like you know if I do this
you're not marrying any dude let's say
you do give up your life for your wife
want her to just live a lonely life
yeah as a black as it all mania really
what my deal will be is take my thumb
and have six babies and after that [ __ ]
whoever you won't get that big girl your
ghost is in the room I get that dead
girl get it I am NOT a [ __ ] blocker and
just one or [ __ ] to be destroyed before
it happens
no it's because kids that's my Empire
nice she's bragging now that's my Empire
you know what I mean so if I die I'm
immortal through them my DNA keeps
going on right so I don't give a [ __ ] I
got six chances of living that's that's
what I'm thinking about I don't think it
works like that it does and when I
reincarnate it comes back to my DNA so
I'll be there only if you're buried in
the proper way to bear off your own
offsprings offspring I'll go into one of
the babies but if you're not buried in a
proper way you won't ring incarnate you
know that well I got a guy like a Viking
or else I won't go to Baja and bombed
exactly you can bomb but that's yeah the
[ __ ] Egyptians do their like gift of
being bombed if the [ __ ] have it
pyramid over here or whatever the [ __ ]
you need to Pyrus up your [ __ ] or
something yeah exactly but that's my
deal what the [ __ ] going on with your
ears it just felt like stretching a
judge the only guy I know who always
seems high no matter what all right live
doctor here was 43 years old he suffered
from chest pains and struggled to
breathe that sounds like a heart attack
so you just say that you died for myself
exhaustion I think that sounds like
gothic oh ho that's scary cuz then when
I get tired I don't want to die
he leaves behind the $10 10 a $10 kid a
10 year-old daughter damn if I went five
months oh my god leave behind the $10.00
kid dollar got it anyway if you leaves
behind a ten-year-old daughter a five
month old son and a wife who's a doctor
at the same hospital oh damn why the
wife is a doctor at the hospital as well
you know how hard must have beat I have
a ten-year-old in a five-month book it's
still gonna be me doctor but the doctor
wants Katie and I have kids because
Isaac's already 10 yeah so you're having
kids real bad soon oh no that means JK
news is gonna disappear no not gonna
tell us the news David I even can't tell
us the news excuse me that is
who wants this job man
damn no one could do it as good as you
you you you can't handle that [ __ ]
job people think they know you won't
survive no [ __ ] cry if you have one
of us do it all the facts are all [ __ ]
up yeah also gonna create our own yeah
cuz my opinions already gonna be
abandoned in the story yeah I just have
no ability to care about what the story
is you know that's my she's gonna give
up can you memorize 26 articles and
perform them within a 10 hour period
absolutely absolutely not thanks guys
thank you for staying one they all look
pretty dire picture taken 30 years ago
oh my god it's your dad well he already
died what happened in this case what do
you mean that's embalmed or something I
don't know his dad it's a scary looking
pretty agent you know Asia like every
single picture that you take always has
that light filter cuz he took some
passport pictures out in Asia and he
that he [ __ ] had that that blurred
filter where it made his skin look
lighter and less blemishes snapchat
filters in Asia huh but then again what
actually my head look like your dad too
so yeah very typical Asian face that I
have anybody that's around or rotund I'm
pretty much there I don't know how long
of a duration he was working for but he
ended up treating 40 patients in the ER
we could probably map this okay well how
long does it take to treat one patient
depends it could be 30 minutes it can be
an hour to be 10 minutes yeah times 40
40 hours I feel like we're like the man
the super math club right now
yeah or 80 hours it was two hours per
patient and it depends on the procedure
what would be crazy is if he died of
exhaustion just [ __ ] weighing people
in that room what if their rule over
staff that night under staff that night
and doctor got away they've got to do
that that would be Chinese like is your
surgeon I don't know they just think he
works in the ER yeah so he gave cough
medicine to 14 so you could be that good
I would like to believe that he saved 40
lives dr. Lana
I don't want to be like 40 bandages and
then he dies usually people that go in
the ER pretty [ __ ] up car crashed
gunshot wounds yeah I hadn't ammonia I
went to the ER L [ __ ] all over the
place I cut my I cut my hand one time on
account on a can of cat food and I had
to go to the ER to get a ticket three
stitch dude cats are the death of you
man I'm slowly killing you I'm not cons
are dating I would say this you know
what my favorite part of those
weight-loss shows are is when they get
them on the scale and then they're
surprised about the number actually it
makes me laugh every time it's not
really that's the part that I love about
the show the most and after that after
that part I don't watch it anymore
because I just like to laugh at that
moment do you do you watch those like
celebrity fitness
there's always those shows because it's
number one I think it'll try to motivate
me but it doesn't but number two wait
for that moment well that person is like
400 pounds and they get on there and
they go it's 4:20 and they go that's
impossible I was like look at you how is
that impossible how did you are oh so
you like Department they first get on
the scale yes I make it so shot I don't
understand why because they're like huge
what if they go that's it then would you
feel better would crack don't [ __ ] up
you're just like no tell them stuff
that's clearly they're like five foot
four right and then 300 pounds they go
well you're very close to getting the
heart set let me go I've never heard
somebody say that to me before
yeah liar I love this [ __ ] where they're
like it's like it's like you got a guy's
like for 90 pounds right and they like
open that part of the states like it's a
game show like they're gonna give him a
car but instead it's like a bunch of
[ __ ] barrels of [ __ ] and something
like that's 480 pounds
that's what say the [ __ ] that they do
make me luck it makes me laugh very hard
because of terrible on it it's great you
know some [ __ ] up [ __ ] though they
forced up contestants to take diet pills
and [ __ ] do you really but they don't
elementary yeah well I'm taking away
from that is that dipoles working
they're losing weight what about their
health yeah I think I like heart
problems and stuff yeah come on David
it's more than diet pills it's like
steroids sometimes
no that would I gain it back after the
show yes makes me feel terrible because
these people lose like 40 pounds in a
week it's like how the [ __ ] is that
possible
and it gets pretty nuts too cuz like and
I'm not even make it fun here it's like
they're wearing a shirt or whatever and
then you see their [ __ ] fat flabby
coming onto this shirt because they lost
so much weight so fast their skins like
yes it's like it's not they can't be
helping it's crazy
it's really sad cuz it's almost like
they're treating them like racehorses
and then it's like I'm gonna get my
racehorses to [ __ ] beat everybody
else yeah force them we're not forced to
but like they they shape it to where
like they trigger traumatic emotional
things so there's drama and like just so
people at home can watch and go oh wow
plus a lot of those people have like
weird things with food right like where
it's like involving emotional abuse and
all that yeah yeah yeah and then they
put them in on like a [ __ ] cupcake
room and they're like let's just [ __ ]
see what happens with that we put a bit
of cupcake rub and he eats it cause
they're like if you if you don't eat
anything or like you can have a [ __ ]
cupcake but it'll hurt you in the next
that [ __ ] challenge thing or whatever
and these cats are like little [ __ ]
sweating like walk into a with a [ __ ]
40 right and just be like hey you guys
can smell it okay or or you get this
prize for the next challenge it's weird
it's very entertaining I agree I think I
think this should be another one called
like like the biggest crackhead oh I
like the title so far the title is
actually really good yeah and it's it's
kind of like the same way but it'll be
like celebrities or like people that
fell off and then like now they're like
addicted to crack or whatever and then
like so far this is just Dancing with
the Stars and you get them in the room
and you try to like get them to quit and
like it's gonna be super inspirational
but then they'll be like sometimes
there's a room full of crack what you
gonna do or like you have to like
deliver drugs for this drug dealer and
it's like don't smoke it on the way yeah
but do when people have food addictions
it's like it's very similar to that
[ __ ] crack [ __ ] dude like I
personally know somebody right
where this person cannot that's not me
this person kidnap we're all thinking
you know it was not me I'll see you
myself it's way worse than make mine
because like I've see this person like
when they eat they [ __ ] light up it's
like somebody's taking a hit or some
[ __ ] dude sounds like me if not like you
I get that with fried cheese I love food
like it just lights them up if they
don't get it everything shuts down
really like depressed angry sad it's
like I've never seen that [ __ ] before
it's kind of weird like I didn't realize
that you can get addicted to food in
that type of manner and so like this
person is like struggling with their
weight and it doesn't matter what you
tell them it's that the joy that they
get from eating something that they like
it's it overpowers everything that's all
sorry
[Music]
[Music]